good morning believe nation today's
message is go for it over to you taraji
P Henson I'm graduated college and I
have you know this degree in fine arts
and my dad saw me coming and going to
work every day and he was like what are
you doing and I was like making a living
what are you talking about and I was in
a transitional period because my son and
father and I we had just broken up and I
had this degree and I was just living
and my dad saw it he was like how do you
expect to catch fish on dry land I was
like he always spoke in metaphors can
you just speak plain English he was like
how are you gonna get acting jobs when
they're not here you need to go to LA
where the jobs are so my family threw a
party we were broke they raised $700 and
I moved to LA and I took my son in my
dad may rest in peace he was like maybe
you should leave Marcell here and I was
like I'm not leaving my son it's not kid
then I got out and freaked out I said
maybe I should send them back and my dad
was like no that's your blessing he's
your blessing he's gonna keep you
focused you were right your instinct was
right you should have taken him so $700
and my son is now 21 he's in school now
always in the gym
starting to write and look at me so I
love this message my take on it is I
think there's a lot of people who need
to go all-in who need to have total
commitment who need to burn the boats we
need to have no way back who you know
raised their last $700 and go to LA and
just figure out a way to make it work
we're coming back is so painful or
there's no option that you just have to
go forward and for some people that's
the only way you can get them to take
action like cold turkey I'm done I'm
stopping this and now I'm starting this
and if that's you then you need to
absolutely follow that advice for other
people like me I like doing small tests
I like to tweak I like to measure I like
to see if it's working like to feel how
it's going before I jump all in on
something doing something crazy like
building a business around believe I
would do one thing I would test a video
with testing news
didn't work how do I feel about it and
the ones that I love I'll continue going
on and working with and I'm constantly
running experiments in my life and in my
business to find the thing that I
resonate with that makes me come alive
when I do that I do a little bit more
and a little bit more and a little bit
more where for me if I go in say I'm
only gonna do this without having done
some testing and some ideas behind it
then it's probably not gonna work out
for me I think the important thing
though whether you're the all-in kind of
person or you like to tastin you a
little more risk-averse
is that you do something about it you
got to take some kind of action right
you have this dream to be an actress to
be an entrepreneur to be a singer to be
a writer whatever it is you have this
dream it can't just be a dream whether
you take massive action and go all-in
whether you take massive action start
doing little tests you have to take some
kind of action and I think that's where
a lot of people fall down because that
fear gets in your head because you worry
how people are gonna judge you you're
worried that it's not gonna work out you
were you're gonna lose your house and
lose a lot of money or waste a lot of
time you worry that you don't have the
resources of the skills or the support
or whatever it is for you you have this
fear and so you don't do anything about
it if you look at successful people
there from all kinds of backgrounds
there from all kinds of color and
religion in countries right all sorts of
different personalities some might be
super aggressive and super you know
in-your-face and super intimidating and
super outgoing that others might be you
know really shy and really nervous and
really meet you know there's no one
thing that you have to be to be a
success but the one thing that they all
had in common was they did something
they got started in a big way or a small
way they didn't just think about it and
end up on their deathbed with that song
still in them they did something about
it so if you have that idea that new
thing that you want to try whether
you're going make a big bet on it or a
series of small bets you have to stop
thinking about it
and just go for it so my question of the
day today for you guys is what was the
last thing that you just went
or leave it down the comments below I'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon